Грегорі Журадо з друзями мітингують на ринку в містечку Вільпарізі
за 20 кілометрів від Парижа.
Вони вважають, що давно пора відкрити очі місцевим мешканцям,
розповісти, що тут, імовірно, вже кілька десятиліть поспіль
всі зазнають радіоактивного опромінення.
У 1950-х роках французька армія проводила неподалік ядерні випробування.
У нашій місцевості незвично високий ризик ракових захворювань.
Необхідно щось робити! Ми намагаємося підвищити активність жителів,
щоб люди почали ставити питання.
І в першу чергу армія повинна нарешті відповісти,
що саме відбувалося тут на військових об'єктах.
Ось можливе джерело загрози - форт де Вожур,
військовий об'єкт площею сорок п'ять гектарів.
Понад п'ятдесят років тому тут робили експерименти з ураном,
зокрема випробовували вибухові пристрої для атомних бомб.
Грегорі Журадо багато років брав участь у місцевій політиці.
Це паризьке передмістя знайоме йому з дитинства.
Він пам'ятає, як, граючи у футбол, часто чув глухі вибухи.
Тоді всі замислювалися, чи це небезпечно?
Але згодом люди заспокоювали себе:
мовляв, за двадцять кілометрів від Парижа не може відбуватися нічого по-справжньому лихого.
Але, можливо, місцеві мешканці  просто не знали правди.
Поступово з'являється нова інформація.
Влітку цього року тут виявили мішки з радіоактивними відходами.
Їх знайшли співробітники французької фірми будматеріалів,
що купила ділянку землі для видобутку гіпсу.
Тепер підприємство має провести дезактивацію території,
хоча ніхто не знає, що ж тут дійсно відбувалося.
Інформація про ядерні експерименти засекречена військовими.
Представник фірми запевняє, що вони уважні й обережні.
Взагалі-то тут лише земля,
але якщо ми знаходимо предмети, які здаються нам незвичними,
то запрошуємо фахівця, який займається дезактивацією.
Грегорі Жураду і його соратники вважають такий підхід безвідповідальним.
Вони звернулися до недержавної Комісії незалежних досліджень
та інформації про радіоактивність у місті Валанс на півдні Франції.
Фізик-ядерник Брюно Шарейрон демонструє,
що, наприклад, одна сторона плитки може бути абсолютно безпечною,
а інша - сильно опромінена.
Так само може бути і з ґрунтом на військовій базі.
У такому місці слід проводити дуже ретельні дослідження.
Після видалення прошарку землі треба заново вимірювати радіоактивність.
Заражені і незаражені місця можуть перебувати зовсім поруч.
Іноді лише кілька сантиметрів відділяють радіоактивний ґрунт від чистого.
Незважаючи на небезпеку опромінення, фірма "Плакоплатр"
продовжує реалізовувати свій план.
Цілком можливо, що в ході ґрунтових робіт
заражені і незаражені прошарки змішуються.
Французьке агентство ядерної безпеки розробило приписи для таких робіт,
утім не здійснює суворого нагляду за їхнім виконанням.
Фірма "Плакоплатр" передусім самостійно несе відповідальність за захист від радіації.
Ми ж не можемо виділити поліцейських, щоб вони слідкували за кожною вантажівкою.
Це не наше завдання.
Але ж це скандал! - обурюється Грегорі Журадо.
Він переконаний, що держава хоче  просто позбутися радіоактивного баласту.
Очевидно, що у держави і фірми будматеріалів спільні інтереси.
одного боку, Франція хоче, щоб про ядерні випробування всі якомога швидше забули,
а "Плакоплатр" у свою чергу хоче скоріше розпочати видобуток гіпсу.
Грегорі Журадо має намір боротися доти,
доки не будуть розкриті всі деталі
про ядерні випробування у форту де Вожур.